on est beaucoup porté par de la colère
puis un peu l'indignation parce que on
est parent ou dans mon caudéran parent
d'enfant qui habite soit le quartier ou
auto et on sait les po puis autour de la
femme dans notre petit arrêt il
pleinement qui était placée pour
connaître ces informations en théorie
médias mais on est autour de la terre
moi j'étais justement d'un réseau de la
santé la colère elle est là parce qu'on
se dise à votre bon sens qu'on n'ait pas
su voir celui qu'on savait que le
diplôme qui allait de réhabilitation de
sols ont pensé que c'est limité dans le
quartier c'était des jours un peu
inquiète pas mais on s'attendait pas à
ce qu'il y ait des rejets ou si
important
alors oui à rouyn noranda la population
et les médecins se mobilise près de la
fonderie rhône les quantité d'arsenic
dépasse largement la norme permise au
québec une cinquantaine de médecins de
la région lance un ultimatum au premier
ministre le go pour que la santé de la
population passe avant tous les autres
intérêts le collège des médecins appuyé
cette demande j'en parlerai dans un
instant avec les députés et ministres
lessard terriens de rouyn noranda
témiscamingue
bonsoir à vous
soit est d'abord avec 7 avec
l'initiatrice de cette lettre la
docteure marie pierre lemieux elle est
médecin de famille au gmf de rouyn
noranda bonsoir madame
bonsoir alors commençons d'abord vous et
vos collègues donc vous êtes visiblement
inquiet vous adresser cette lettre
ouverte au premier ministre le go vous
êtes inquiet pour la santé de la
population vous êtes des médecins est ce
que dans votre pratique membres vous
avez vu des effets de ces émissions hors
norme d'arsenic dans la région
en fait comme je l'aï expliqué à
certains de vos collègues journalistes
occupent tout l'enjeu en fait c'est que
dans une dans une population comme
celles qu'on peut suivre comme et un ami
ou comme groupe de médecins c'est
impossible de voir un effet de ce genre
de situation parce que c'est une trop
petite population va nous prend vraiment
des choses qui nous permet d'avoir une
population plus globale un peu comme ce
que la santé publique nous ont offert le
comme études dans les dernières semaines
c'est vraiment ce genre d'étude le qui
peut nous permettre deux d'avoir une
idée plus générale de stu sport c'est de
mieux comprendre le vraiment les impacts
que ça peu avant sur la santé parce qu'à
l'échelle d'une puce de type population
donc ce n'est pas parce que voulait
constater mais c'est parce que vous
pensez que les émissions sachant que les
émissions la sonic dépasse largement les
normes ça c'est un fait connu vous
redoutez des effets pour la santé de la
population
en fait on fait plus que les redoutés on
le sait parce qu'un enfant les données
de la santé publique nous démontre qu'il
y a plus de cancers vivement à rouyn
noranda que dans le reste de la province
il y a plus maladie pulmonaire
obstructive chronique il ya plus de
bébés de faible poids qui naissent et
l'espérance de vie est de 1 an moindre
donc ce sont également les ché et comme
vous l'avez bien mentionné à coller aux
faibles qu'on sait que de nombreux
contaminants dans l'air qui dépasse
largement largement les normes établies
belle à deux et deux font quatre c'est
ça alors donc pour vous le lien de cause
à effet entre les émissions hors norme
de la fonderie rhône et ses problèmes de
santé pour vous le vient de cause à
effet même s'il est pas encore établie
scientifiquement il nous apparaît
évident je pense qu'en fait on ne peut
pas se permettre d'attendre qu'un lien
de causalité françois établies parce que
dans une population aussi petite que
celle de rouyn noranda ce sera toujours
difficile parce que les chiffres ne
seront jamais suffisamment élevé pour
que la signification statistique soient
suffisantes donc il faut se contenter en
guinée de ses de six éléments le connaît
déjà mais qui sont largement suffisants
à notre avis pour sonner la la cela dit
j'ai quand même pourquoi pourquoi cette
lettre ouverte maintenant précisément
parce que bon les données on vous
parlait il ya des études depuis mme 2019
la députée qu'on va interviewer tout à
l'heure se bat depuis 2009 pourquoi vous
signez ça vous aujourd'hui comme médecin
en fait c'est sûr que la situation et
les prix que préoccupante depuis 2010
9,1 en 2010 9 ce qu'on a mais c'est l
imprégnation dans le sens d'aider des
personnes montre que les gens avaient
une quantité d'arsenic le dans les
ongles à ce moment là qu'ils étaient
mesures est supérieure à la moyenne et
le ce qu'on se demandait est ce pourquoi
on n'avait pas de donner c'est l'impact
sur la santé tels que ceux qu'ont les
gens ne va pas chez oui mais est-ce que
ça fait vraiment quelque chose dans le
fond d'abord des poux dans les ongles
plus élevés d'arsenic de métaux lourds
et je dirais que ce qui a changé dans
les dernières semaines ce sont les
données que la santé publique nous a
fourni à l'effet que oui clairement il
ya plus de malades il ya diminution de
la longévité ça c'est un problème c'est
clairement on a quelque chose de concret
à se mettre sous la dent et le je pense
que les gens sont plus à l'aise de
nommer clerc maxime ça me fait peur
voilà alors donc c'est très clair ce que
vous demander monsieur legault c'est
finalement de ne permettre à la fonderie
horne de nîmes être que ce qui permit
ailleurs dans la province les mêmes
normes devraient s'appliquer la mélasse
et ce sera énorme comme réduction
franchement c'est elle et elle est à
moins de 90 ce nano grammes par mètre
cube faudrait l'a ramenée à 3,9 g par
mètre cube
exactement en fait il n'y a pas de
raison que les la population de rouyn
n'ai pas accès à la même qualité d'air
que le reste du québec c'est ça le
message essentiel que nous on veut
passer on a droit à la même qualité
d'arc ailleurs si la norme c3 dans le
rôle du québec est bien la norme ça
devrait être trois également à prendre
en date d'autant plus qu'on a commencé a
démontré des effets sur la santé de la
population ce n'est plus acceptable de
tolérer plus peut-être que ça a été
acceptable longtemps à cause des jobs
des emplois créés par la fonderie you je
pense cela représente 600 emplois
peut-être même que parmi vos patients il
ya des gens qui travaillent là où des
gens qui ont des parents qui travaillent
là
est ce que est ce que ceci explique cela
peut-être
mais très certainement salue un impact
parce que dans l'histoire de la v la
fonderie a toujours été très très très
présentes et sont en confiance et quand
on regarde l'historique aussi le bébé le
temps monumental en lien avec la
fonderie historiquement les médecins ont
toujours été très très prudents dans
leurs prises de position parce qu'il y
avait tout l'enjeu de la
des enjeux sociaux aussi de la santé le
compte des enjeux économiques et tout ça
mais là je pense que présentement en
2022 à rouyn noranda on n'est plus en
mesure de payer school pour avoir une
relance économique ça fait plus de sens
de continuer à ce que les gens payent ce
prix le dollar sans une dernière
question très très rapidement le docteur
boileau directeur par intérim de la
santé publique du québec se rend à rouyn
demain à quoi vous attendez-vous de sa
part
je m'attends à ce que ou du moins
j'espère très fortement que docteur
boileau sera d'accord et unir en savoie
à la nôtre pour exiger exactement la
même chose en chef du gouvernement et de
monsieur legault ce qu'on demande c'est
revenir à la norme et j'espère que
monsieur voile ou sera d'accord allez dr
le mieux merci beaucoup au revoir merci
à vous bonne soirée
alors je poursuis maintenant avec
emily's les stars terriens député
solidaire de rouyn noranda témiscamingue
pour soi par internet soit maintenant
alors les médecins ont leur vienne
l'entendre veulent que les normes
d'émission d'arsenic soient les mêmes à
rouyn noranda émises par la fonderie
ronde les mêmes qu'ailleurs au québec
est ce que la réponse du cabinet du
premier ministre qui a répondu
aujourd'hui par texte là en disant qu'on
y travaille est qu'on est en train de
négocier avec la faune nerone que l on
les avait réduits et déjà
considérablement mais que j'étais encore
trop élevé est-ce que vous avez
sentiment qu'on va finir par arriver aux
mêmes normes qu'ailleurs
j'ai si on y arrive c'est parce qu'il y
aurait eu une mobilisation historique du
côté de rouyn noranda cette mobilisation
elle est en train de prendre vraiment de
naissance et prendre de l'ampleur
réduire les émissions d'arsenic c'est le
discours de la caf depuis le jour 1
depuis 2009 x man par qui on ne sait
toujours ce qu'ils ont dit maintenant
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait pour que ça se
passe réellement est-ce qu'ils ont
rehaussé les exigences parce que la
fonderie yonne elle va jouer dans les
limites du carré de sable que veut lui
donner le gouvernement du québec en ce
moment le carré de sable que lui donne
la cac ces 33 fois la norme du québec et
c'est ce qui n'est pas acceptable
ils sont en train de renégocier la
prochaine cible est de faire le mieux le
bien dit la prochaine cible elle n'a pas
d'autre choix que d'être la norme
québécoise et je pense qu'à l'heure
actuelle la quête est totalement perdu
confiance la confiance des gens de rouyn
noranda qui ont l'impression que les
impératifs économiques priem sur leur
propre santé et si laquelle veut
regagner la confiance des gens points de
rang d'heure elle n'aura pas le choix
d'exiger de 3,9 est ce que est ce que
vous diriez que les gouvernements qui se
sont succédés qui ont de accordé ce
passe droit en son temps c'est un passe
droit il ya d'autres fonderies au québec
qui n'émettent pas comme le fait la
fonderie roanne n'est ce pas
mais en fait la fonderie yole comme elle
est en activité depuis
la fin des années 20 elle comme un droit
acquis de polluer le nom scientifique
pour ça c'est les attestations
d'assainissement il ya eu définitivement
du laxisme pendant des décennies et le
droit d'aimer 67 fois la norme du québec
pendant six ans il ya eu des longs
moments où ces attestations de va être
renouvelée qui avait juste rien qui se
passe et ça c'est l'héritage du
gouvernement libéral c'est l'héritage du
gouvernement péquiste et là c'est
l'héritage du gouvernement de la
coalition vie à venise québec et le ou
la donne change c'est que maintenant on
allait donner on a les données et donc
moi je maintenant s'il ya un juste en
dessus qui doit poser une question qu'on
veut du poilu la fonderie est ce qu
est-ce que c'est facile de faire ça
parce qu'on voit qu'elle a négocié la
une diminution petit à petit la est-ce
que c'est facile techniquement parlant
pour une fonderie comme la fonderie
horne qui est une grosse fonderie ce que
c'est facile de réduire ses émissions de
passer de 90 nanogrammes par mètre cube
à 3 microgrammes par mètre cube
mais en fait je pense qu est-ce qui est
pas facile c'est de mettre la main dans
sa poche et maëlys où ça prend pour
atteindre les moyens technologiques pour
y arriver on parle de contrôle et des
poussières d hymne des émanations
fugitive donc c'est quand les camions
sur le site de la fonderie circulent
quand on brasse le matériel qui rendent
balafon brise sacré de la poussière et
c'est sa maman qui se retrouvent dans
les poumons des gens parlant de rouyn
noranda
glencore parce que la fonderie ans est
une propriété de glencore qui est une
multinationale suisse qui aurait mis
dans les poches de ses actionnaires 4
milliards de dollars en février
donc la question c'est à voir c'est
simplement savoir combien oui mais
est-ce qu'il faut parce que le
gouvernement est prêt à aider
financièrement l'entreprise pour qu'elle
mette ses installations à niveau est ce
qu est ce qu on devrait payer pour ça
mais moi je pense que la réponse est non
le grand corps aux les moyens d'investir
dans les mesures environnementales pour
prévenir la santé de la population de
rouyn noranda le gouvernement du québec
son rôle c'est de légiférer pour
restreindre les carrés de sable dans les
elle veut jouer la fonderie et ce n'est
pas de subventionner cette entreprise là
qui nous rend malade pour être on paye
déjà suffisamment cher avec nos soins
semble alors avec avec notre santé qui
tripotait qui alors reste à voir si
l'entente sera rendu public qui est
négocié avant les élections du 3 octobre
émise le starter lien député solidaire
de rouyn noranda témiscamingue merci
beaucoup au revoir merci à vous bonne
paris pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit